hello there today we're looking at
language models as zero shot planners
extracting actionable knowledge for
embodied agents and i'm going to
interview the first author wen long
huang in a few minutes so first there's
an explanation of the paper 10 15
minutes or so i'm gonna try to keep to
it and then we jump into the interview
where we can discuss this paper at
length on a high level this paper asks
can we use the knowledge that is
inherent in large language models like
gpt3 or surprisingly open ai's codecs in
order to do planning in what they call
embodied agents ultimately it's going to
be this environment right here the uh i
don't even know what it's the virtual
home environment and it's about a
virtual home you have to fulfill some
tasks like brushed your teeth then the
model has to come up with a sequence of
steps that are admissible by the
environment so there's a level of
admissibility of action predefined
actions that are admissible the model
has to come up with these actions in
order to fulfill the task the model is
then rated based on executability and
correctness of their plans and it turns
out that the larger the models get as
you can see right here the less
executable the plans become which means
that the actions they generate aren't
admissible by the environment probably
because the models are more let's say
powerful they can express themselves in
more ways they have different ideas of
how to reach goals however the
correctness this is human evaluated of
these models rise as they grow larger so
this gives you an indication that the
large models seem to have quite a lot of
knowledge and we have to say these are
not trained the entire paper just works
except for one baseline evaluation just
works with pre-trained models they are
not fine-tuned at all on this
environment right here so what this
paper does is it says well given that
the larger the models get the more
correct their plans are can we do
something to fix the issue with the
executability to that they develop this
translation procedure right here these
are three specific improvements they do
to the models in order to get their
executability up you can see they
sacrifice like a little bit of the
correctness but they do make the plans
largely executable in the environment
and therefore procedures like this could
be applied in many different ways it's
not only about the virtual home
environment and so on it's essentially
anywhere where you bring together the
knowledge that is inherent in large
language models with some sort of a
domain specific language or a grammar or
any anything like this like where you
have to transfer that knowledge into a
new domain but you don't want to train a
model to do so so we're going to see how
they do it really briefly first of all
the environment itself as i already said
is this now this is visualized although
they never work you know actually in 3d
just a small correction here because i
messed this up there are actually two
versions of the virtual home environment
one is a python version that focuses on
the textual interaction with the
environment the other one is implemented
in unity and actually does work in 3d
the developers of the environment mostly
focus on the unity environment because
it's more real but as of yet that has a
subset of the actions available that the
python environment has and the authors
of the paper use the python environment
and the data set that comes along with
that we're going to go into this more in
the interview stay tuned they simply
grab the data set of possible tasks some
tasks you can see right here a task
could be throwaway paper another task
could be brush teeth and there there be
a sequence of steps this environment is
made by humans so the tasks are made by
humans and then other humans have to
come up with the steps that are
admissible admissible actions in this
environment there are i believe a number
of objects that are defined they're
predefined yeah so there are a number of
objects for example living room
television sofa and so on and there are
a number of verbs so walk find uh switch
on and so on and not every verb object
combination is possible some verbs have
two objects and so on but essentially
you combine the predefined verbs and the
predefined objects and then the state of
the world changes so the world keeps
track of states there are certain
preconditions for example you can
probably only sit on the sofa if you are
in the vicinity of it so you need to
first find the sofa you can only
switch on the television similarly if
you have first found the television or
walked to the television or something
like this if the television is in the
living room you first need to go to the
living room and so on so there's a
hidden kind of a state but all of this
is constructed and we talk about this in
the interview like what's the
appropriate granularity of actions like
this and isn't this a major issue but it
is made all with the humans in the loop
so the data set is supposed to be kind
of the most natural expression of these
tasks uh split into steps that a human
would come up with so this is the
grammar of the environment and the
language models they don't they don't
know about this grammar they're just
language models so what they do is they
take something like gpt3 and they make a
prompt now the prompt as you might know
in gpthree you have to give a prompt so
the prompt could just be like here's the
task you know blah blah blah brush your
teeth then what's step one
right and then gpt3 will probably it
will probably even generate step two and
three and four but it will probably not
be according to the these actions in
these templates you can help this a
little bit by putting a prompt up here
so the prompt they use is one i believe
one specific plan so they have already
like task up here some tasks and then
some number of steps so that the model
kind of knows what is expected we also
talk about this in the interview then
this could potentially be improved um by
multiple multiple prompts and so on but
in the baseline they have one particular
prompt and then one of the improvements
is actually to select the more optimal
prompt this is the basic setup you have
a goal in this environment with a fixed
grammar
and you task you input this right here
to your language model
and the language model will spit out the
plan now what do you do with the plan
the plan
you score like how good is the plan and
they have two different scorings
available one is executability and
executability is just like it's
essentially parsability by the
environment so in executability you ask
yourself can it be correctly parsed
which means that is the syntax according
to the syntax of the environment and
they do have a little translation
procedure like a little heuristic
translation procedure for the baseline
in place so that the language model
probably can't get it exactly right but
they do sort of translate to the closest
action there but also one of the
improvements is related to this and then
also does it satisfy the common sense
constraints of the environment and these
would be programmed in like for example
you can only pour yourself a glass of
milk if you first open the fridge and
and grab the milk this can be measured
directly what cannot be measured that
well is correctness so these models they
would come up with plans and independent
of whether they're executable or not
they could be correct right and that's
where they ask humans so they use human
evaluations they conduct human
evaluations in order to score the
correctness of whatever these models
output so they give it to a human ask
the human does this look like a sensible
plan in order to brush your teeth and
the human would either say yes or no
when they do like ablations and so on
they also use like longest common
subsequences between two programs and so
on in order to not spend ginormous
amounts of money on humans but
essentially the correctness metric is a
human metric it's also interesting
because you you thought you could just
execute like the plan in the environment
and that give you like does it succeed
or not but they say correctly that for a
task like make breakfast there's not
really a defined end condition that you
could program into the environment to
give a reward so it's more accurate to
ask humans whether a plan is correct as
you might have guessed this environment
is very human-centric it's made by
humans with humans in the loop and so on
it's supposed to really be sort of a
representation of of human tasks and
human plans to human tasks all right
so now we're going into the improvements
there are three distinct improvements
they make so if they just do this if
they just do what we've described so far
then the graph up here results
excluding the two models on the right
you can see the larger the models get
the higher their correctness but the
worse their executability so now the
thought is can we change that can we
raise the executability
and so this is the baseline right here
zero shot planning via causal large
language model you put in a task
as a prompt
and along with like the format you
expect which is this one right here
which is some other task from the data
set then you use the pre-trained
language model like gpt3 or something
and that will give you a plan and that's
it so the next thing they do is they do
what they call a
translation model so they introduce a
second model which is also pre-trained
and this is it's not trained on
translation it's just trained on masked
large language modeling so think of this
like this is just bird in fact i believe
they use sentence bird
just pre-trained on english language and
what they do is they make a big
vocabulary of all the admissible actions
so all the admissible actions would just
be like any combination between any verb
and any object that would actually go
with that that is admissible to this
verb so from this they make like a giant
list
of all
of the admissible actions
and then they embed that giant list so
they put this into some embedding space
using the sentence bert model
pre-trained right
and then whenever the large language
model outputs something they don't
implement it into the plan directly they
first embed whatever the model outputs
let's put this over here they embed it
let's say that becomes this right here
then
they see what's the nearest neighbor of
my admissible actions to this thing and
then they simply replace whatever the
model output with the nearest neighbor
and they call that they call that
translation so essentially it translates
from general natural language space into
the space of the admissible actions or
the grammar of the model now this has
some problems on its own for example if
the model outputs the compound actions
so if it says for example
squeeze out the glob of lotion and put
it in your mouth or so or or on your
face i guess then
well it's apply lotion it's anywhere
squeeze out the glob of lotion and put
it on your skin that would be still one
action now which one would be the
closest right here there's gonna be
somewhere like uh squeeze out a bit of
lotion and the other one is gonna be
like put the lotion on your skin yet you
only have one action like it's it's it's
one line so one action it just contains
like an and now the end might be easy to
recognize but there are other they're
going to be other like compound actions
and this is going to be a problem here
because you just map one action to one
admissible action but in any case doing
this already helps a lot even though
there are still some problems to
alleviate the rest of the problems they
have two more improvements the first
improvement they do is they say well if
there's a compound action we can still
kind of alleviate that a little bit so
in the original method what they did is
they simply took this through the
through the language model and they got
out just a list of steps right here is
step one here is step two here is step
three and so on that is just a list of
steps and they would translate even when
they use the translation model they
would translate each of them to
a admissible action translate this one
to an admissible action well now you
have no idea of whether that sequence of
admissible actions even makes sense
right for example one could be a
compound action and it just gets
translated to one of the two actions and
then the next action doesn't have a
precondition so what they do is they
interleave the two steps right they
interleave this translation with the
generation so they would only generate
one step at a time like step one then
they would translate it and then they
would use the translated version and put
it back into the language model to get
step two that way the language model
always is conditioned on admissible
actions instead of just being free form
and then translating after the fact so
this is auto-regressive generation
the last improvement they make which is
i guess more of a minor improvement
that's why it's not in this diagram
however what they do is instead of
having a generic prompt what they do is
they take the task
uh they embed it using the same
sentence bird embedding
and they compare it to um to embeddings
of all of the tasks that they have in
the data set and they just pick the
closest task in the data set to act as a
prompt which could still transfer some
in-context knowledge in you know for the
current task so that is
essentially the method they investigate
this they have a algorithm right here
they also like they
it's i'm i formulated it in a rather
easy way but they do not only consider
the closest action they consider
actually awaiting of in so in the
translation they consider a waiting uh
between how close it is it to an
admissible action and how likely is that
action
that they that they output so they would
generate
not only one action and then translate
it they would actually generate a bunch
of variants and they consider each one
of them like how close is it to an
admissible action and also how likely is
it and then they take the best
combination of the two that is obviously
modulated by a hyperparameter
they have early stopping and all of this
kinds of stuff and this results in this
results in a neat uh in a neat
algorithm that and we're going to talk
about these things in a bit and also the
uh
also the results right here i just i
want to highlight that if you look at
for example vanilla gpt3 has a really
low executability it does have a high
correctness
however if you look at the translated
version which is after their
improvements you can see the
executability has risen dramatically
while the correctness is a bit lower
like you get a bit lower in correctness
because of the whole translation
procedure and so on you're mocking with
the outputs humans may not like it as
much this is all stuff we're going to
touch on in the interview just
interestingly highlighting that
codex like the codex model seems to be
scoring quite well on these tasks so
also the translated codex
is much smaller however it scores high
really high so parameter for parameter
the codex model is actually pretty
pretty good at this which was a surprise
to me so i think this is an exciting
paper it it except as i said for a
fine-tuning baseline it turns out to
work with completely without any
training it's just evaluation so to say
and i liked it and i think this does
have applications like getting the
knowledge out of these large language
models is something
we should you know be getting better at
doing otherwise i don't think we make
full use of them all right so now i want
to jump into the interview with wen long
i hope you enjoy that as well tell me
how you like these these videos with the
interviews without the interviews
anything you want in the comments i'll
see ya bye bye
[Music]
welcome everyone uh today with me here
is wen long huang who is the first
author of the paper about language
models as zero shot planners and very
very happy to have you here uh welcome
wen long
thank you yannick yeah super super happy
to be here
this is i i've already told you but this
paper is different and i like different
papers and um it's it's different in a
way that
maybe
wasn't
expected every it seems like every day
we find new applications for these large
language models and yet another thing
that they can do here and when i when i
saw this i was
reminded of a friend of mine who had
like similar ideas but it never really
materialized i tried some of this stuff
as well combining large language models
with planning with telling me what to do
in the real world i even made a video
where
gpt3 told me a recipe and then i cooked
the rest like me and my friend we cooked
the recipe and so on but it seemed like
always a bit um
a bit out of place a bit a bit off just
to give you detailed instructions and
when i saw a paper that was really
trying to make this work in a real
environment uh i was i was very happy to
see that uh and yeah that's that is that
is this paper and also to be said you
have a you have a stellar board of of uh
co collaborators right here um how how
did this come about like how did you
even get to the idea hey i could use
these language models to do planning was
it like did it immediately come to you
did it sort of build up from some
basic idea or what was the process
so yeah um thanks for the brief intro i
think that's actually came out to be
really surprising to us as well so first
we were just having
when we just played around with
the largest language models on the on
many of the web
interface uh we found that like
actually there's something there like
you said if you
ask it for a recipe or uh we actually
originally study um like whether you can
out for the steps for making coffee et
cetera so we found that like when the
months get large enough there's actually
something there and this is the sign of
life i think um for us
to kind of um go on and investigate how
we can make that actually um useful for
for
agents so um we kind of just started
from there and actually uh it came out
to be pretty surprising originally we
thought like maybe we need some training
data set to
maybe like train something a translator
or something to actually make it useful
but it turns out like uh but we're
really trying to constrain ourselves in
in the meantime because we don't want it
to be tailored to a specific environment
so we just want to
see
like just the language model itself like
how how well can do how far again goes
so uh this is what god got us in the end
um
we just like uh explored for like two
months and then found like you can
actually do this uh without any any
training and um it yeah it's actually
truly um surprising and actually um
actually a really fun project for me as
well
just
it sounds like fun yeah just trying to
see uh whether you can output something
like really uh realistic and and really
fun yeah
yeah so you you came you came across
this this environment right here this um
virtual home environment was this always
the plan or why did you choose like
there are a million environments open ai
gym and and they're they're moving you
know these mujo co
kind of robot simulations why was this
one particularly useful did you
immediately think of this one or how did
this came about thanks yeah so actually
uh i wasn't um doing too much research
in in this uh in body agents uh area
especially for for this like really high
level tasks and then i
actually when went to the like
google scholar and then search for
appropriate environments for this and we
found this virtual home environment and
we we really liked it because it
actually um can model any
uh any tasks if you can express them um
in terms of this like uh textual uh
language plan um like a like just just a
like textual plan so um and actually
there are many many other environments
as well but some of them are limited by
um
i think a lot of people uh also use
alfred environment uh that's a really
good involvement too and i think uh it's
a bit more structured there but um the
tasks are often come from um
like a template so it's usually like
pick something put something um but
actually there are a lot of challenges
there i think it's a different set of
challenges and we found like what the
virtual home tackles um it's exactly
what we look for because
uh it can model like any task expressed
in free form language
especially those like really challenging
tasks like people do actually every day
uh like make breakfast make tea make
coffee and then um it particularly cares
about
the common sense constraints in them so
specifically this environment has
a set of like
preconditions and post conditions for
each action so for example if you want
to grab a glass of milk from from the
fridge you can't just like say go to the
fridge and grab glass of milk because
you first gotta open the fridge first
and then uh like preferably you want to
close the fridge afterwards so it's
really this like um these constraints i
think um
are really useful and
really interesting to study whether
language models can can
handle this
and you you've you've investigated
several different language models and
just to be clear this environment it has
this kind of syntax it has very defined
things you can do and somewhere i think
you say it's about 50 000
actions that are ultimately possible
it's kind of a combination of a bunch of
verbs which are grab open go to and
lift or things like this and a bunch of
objects like kitchen fridge and so on so
any plan would consist of a sequence of
verb object verb object like here a walk
to kitchen open fridge grab milk so the
the
the
any planner in this environment would
have to output this syntax directly now
you
had a plan of not training anything
right you didn't want to train anything
you simply wanted to investigate what
knowledge is already there in the
language models and you came up with
kind of a way to translate that do you
want to maybe elaborate how do you how
do you query these language models and
how do you make them actually conform to
the
to the uh the
the
attacks here of course yeah so um the um
the way that virtual home uh expresses
these actions are
uh via like this specific format where
you put a square bracket um like for the
action atomic action like grab would
open and then you put i think it's a
parenthesis
or yeah something for for the arguments
and um but the the problem is like we
can't just like
expect language models to to handle this
because um i mean even if we put an
example in front maybe they can do it
but it's definitely not the way that
usually humans um produce language so
and after all these language models are
trained on human text so
we decide like maybe it's not the the
right way to query these models maybe we
just want to have you ever tried have
you tried letting them output directly
the syntax or was it just like yeah it's
not going to work anyway i tried briefly
but it's definitely not uh thoroughly
investigated and yeah like
like in intuition-wise i think it's
definitely sure yeah
to to use like natural language but we
did adopt for the um the most basic
approach that we can we can think of
which is like just define
a straight up like
template for each atomic action and
actually because this atomic actions are
uh simple enough like just walk grab and
those things so uh this atomic action i
mean the template the time place we
actually came out
with uh our i think actually
just natural way like people people say
things so like um turn off something
turn on something um and then add uh
some some words in between like in
um on top of etc
and yeah and then and then you you just
query these models and you have multiple
ways of evaluating this right you care
about two things you care about
correctness and you care about uh
executability
and in at least
um
so you also make use of humans like how
did you how did you design like what was
your thinking behind designing the
evaluation
yeah so actually uh it came out to be
really challenging to evaluate these
things um like i said so like um this
this tasks are because they're expressed
in free form language so
that means they're really open-ended so
it might be deterministic whether like
if you want to grab a glass of milk you
just want to look in the end whether you
have a glass of milk but
if you really think about it if we don't
want to constrain
anything in the task that we want to
want to do like making breakfast like
what is the correct way to make
breakfast everyone has different
preferences so it's hard for us uh
actually um i think it's still a
challenge
in this sort of task is like really
determine if the correctness i mean
sorry it's the success rate for each
task so you can't really tell if a task
is really successful
depending on how open-ended it is so uh
we decided that
uh okay so if it's hard to
computationally produce
a metric for a success rate um like but
as humans we can definitely tell if it's
making something semantically meaningful
so uh just uh use part of like human
evaluations to do this but we don't want
to
entirely rely on humans because uh as
you can tell for the uh for the text
that like for the action plan that real
language models generate they're so
realistic that like they can even fool
many humans that are like
too realistic so uh you can't just
entirely rely on humans to to say if
it's successful so we also
uh use this metric executability which
is also used in in past papers from um
in like the uses virtual home so uh we
just use this metric as well to
basically determine whether the plan
satisfy uh the common sense constraints
uh in this environment namely just like
whether you
like open make sure to open the fridge
before grabbing something from it yeah
like this and it's interesting because
when the humans rate it the humans would
also skip a bunch of steps right if you
said if you tell a human go to the
fridge and grab a glass of milk the
human would go like oh yeah of course
all right which is which is one of my um
maybe this is jumping ahead a little bit
but one of the questions i had most when
i read this was just there is a level of
specificity that is required right here
which is kind of ambiguous right you
have a high level description which is
like make breakfast right and then you
have a bunch of steps which you need to
follow and sure these steps correspond
to actions in the environment so they're
kind of given by that but the language
model doesn't know that right the
language model just knows i need to
produce a plan so how is the language
model you know why do why do we expect
the language model to figure out that it
needs to like that it can't
that it needs to say
open the fridge before you get a glass
but it for example it doesn't need to
say put one foot in front of the other
foot you know in order to walk
um so you know did you have any
insights or concerns with like there
seems to be like this very specific
level of specificity of these plans yeah
so that's a really good question
actually um this granularity actually
comes from the data set uh or namely the
ver the virtual home environment itself
because the way um because we
essentially follow the format of uh
virtual home environment and also this
data set they collected for from humans
of how to do
this really uh
like human activity task so the way they
collect they build this environment is
they first
ask um
many humans to come up with a set of
tasks that they do in everyday household
and then they ask a different group of
human to come up with a
detailed plan that contrives a robot to
do to perform these tasks and and
it's after that they build this
environment based on the verbs used by
by those humans so you can think of like
this environment is really built on top
of what humans says now now
the developers um who uh would just say
like okay we want this granularity you
want this like walk grab and those etc
so um they actually asked these humans
to give those words and verbs and then
build those actions uh according to
those verbs and they did make sure to
for each of the verb to develop a set of
common sense constraints which
completely makes sense and i think
they're uh actually um
like
reasonably exhaustive for for for those
actions so if you want to grab something
you definitely need to make sure the
things you grab is not within a closed
container for example so
in this case the fridge is a container
and it has this attribute of uh being
open or being closed so they internally
keep track of the attributes for for
each of the uh each of the object and
then to make sure that like
if you do something like this you don't
violate the um
the common sense constraints so uh to
answer your question so like this this
granularity really depends on the humans
um and like i think this is where
language models really shine because it
essentially language models are trained
on human-produced text so my hypothesis
although this is definitely not
something thoroughly tested but my
hypothesis is that because it's trained
on human-produced text and humans after
all produce these actions
so if you
do uh do it careful enough and then use
some techniques to
properly translate them or
doing something else you can essentially
get back something similar to what
humans produce in the beginning
yeah that's i mean
you would you would imagine that sort of
the humanness of how the environment was
built would also be present a little bit
in these language models which makes
sense i i don't have a better idea like
of how to build an environment like this
so yeah i think it's pretty pretty
reasonable yeah yeah it's actually come
out to be really like uh interesting to
me because it's like it's just super
hard for me uh if i were to develop this
environment like how would you even
animate like
all this like really
like human tasks in in even just in the
household setting it's super difficult
and uh i think they did did a really
good job here and then i think uh this
is also what makes like language models
particularly
useful for for this task because these
are basically just human tasks and
language modes are really good at like
me making humans yeah yeah
yeah so on the on the left here we see a
bunch of models that you've evaluated
right here so again executability is
sort of how like if it if it matches the
syntax of the environment if i can map
it to that and also i guess if it if it
violates any of these common sense
constraints
um so just like how executable is the
plan in the environment no matter
whether it's the wrong thing right and
that comes in in a second and
correctness is a thing that is rated by
human annotators they look at the plan
that was produced and they just from
their own intuition or like well is this
a good plan to make breakfast yes or no
and we clearly see like there is there's
this downward trend if we exclude the
models on the right there is this trend
line here where the larger models they
seem to produce more correct plans which
means plants that the humans like more
but they are less less executable
whereas the smaller models they are
less correct which
you know we can that's correct i would
have expected that but they're more
executable
yeah and you've noticed in the paper
that very often they just produce plans
that have nothing to do with the task
description they would just produce like
a plan
that is according to the syntax of the
examples that you give in the prompt
right um but how can you explain that
like even even on the top here like the
large models it's even better than
humans at correctness
so humans rating other humans think that
gpt-3 produces more correct correct
plans why is it so bad at executability
yeah so uh there are actually two
questions uh that like i think you
erased one is uh why this like smaller
models like um like when i say smaller
it's actually still pretty large the
large
gpt-2 model so why do they produce like
more executable plants uh and the second
question is uh why the gbt3 the larger
gp3 model is actually better than human
so to answer the first question
um
uh i think that's because uh we did find
some failure modes here uh for for
smaller models
i think the two most um prominent ones
are uh first it tries it frequently
tries to
like repeat the given example for
example you give it like how to browse
internet instead i go on computer and
use type on the keyboard etc um and then
you ask it to brush teeth it still goes
like goes to the computer and then and
then type out on the keyboard so it's
totally nothing like sensible here and
then the second source of error is
sometimes it
just outputs really short plans if you
say like uh sleep task uh go to sleep
it's just like go to go go to the
bedroom and and just stops
so um
yeah that's this this right here brush
teeth it's just like go to bathroom yeah
yeah exactly
so so uh when when these plants are
short enough even though it can be
executed like if you just say like walk
to the bathroom and walk to the bedroom
just one single action
like for walk there is not much like uh
common sense countries uh there so like
yeah
you can totally imagine like it's super
executable
but if you present them to humans of
course like humans will spot this and
then say okay this is not correct
because we
when we do human evaluations we we're
trying to make it simple so that the um
the the error here is not too big
because we don't ask like hundreds of
humans to evaluate this we only uh ask
got to ask 10 uh evaluators in this case
so um
uh so that's why like
this smaller models are now really good
at scalability and and the second
question that you ask is why on this
like larger models um
are actually better than humans so uh we
actually this is not a completely fair
comparison if you just look at one axis
so all the results you here we look at
from two axis that we care about so one
is the
semantic correctness which is evaluated
by humans and the second is the
executability so this human plans that
we use
are from this data set that um virtual
home developers uh like crowdsource from
from from amazon turkers so um this
plants they make sure that like these
are executable plants so which means um
that they're they have one like here
yeah they'd be over here yeah but we
don't want to put the spot right there
yeah
on the right because uh it's it's hard
to see because humans are a big um
baseline and reference here uh it's not
the baseline that we're trying to beat
of course like 253 is not there yet in
terms of like uh at the same time
outputting correct action plans and
semantic semantically correct action
plans and also
being able to really ground them in the
environment but yeah
using this to access we can really see
for example
which is the uh which axis is the the
place that as a community that we we may
want to work more on uh to get it better
to to get the human levels and with this
paper that we we kind of find this uh
result uh actually a bit interesting to
us
is that like for for these larger models
uh
like in terms of semantic correctness
you don't need to worry too much about
it it's kind of already there if you uh
if you if you do it um extract them um
but the real question is how do we make
them suitable for
agents that we that we care about and
this and that's exactly what what you do
right in the in like the meat of the
paper and the result are these these
translated models right here uh that you
know notably they do drop a little bit
in terms of their correctness as rated
by humans but they gain massively in
executability and this
is the result of a bunch of different
ingredients like three main ingredients
as far as i could tell you quickly want
to go like tell what like what the
ingredients are to make whatever these
models output into
what something that i mean you know the
virtual home is maybe a test bed right
it's not i don't see this paper being
about virtual home it's more like
here is a model that outputs something
yet i need the output in some other form
right in in this
is a very general problem has many
applications and if we could solve that
bridge that technically is you know is a
big gain that's exactly what you do
so how how did you go about this yeah so
uh actually i just want to make sure
that uh actually this paper just present
a really
like preliminary stuff i i don't think
it solves anything particularly i mean
it does like if this problem sure but
it's a big step i i believe like i mean
you the the executability raises
pretty pretty high i i don't i didn't
want to oversell you but also not not
undersell you certainly yeah so um but
to answer the question so uh so so we
actually found like uh
there's actually uh i just said there
are three ingredients but central to
this uh is a wine simple really simple
technique that we found uh that's the
most useful which is action translation
so um because
in this virtual whole environment the
actions that uh it supports are uh are a
limited set i mean it's not small but
it's something that we can definitely
enumerate with our computational
hardware and in
like in a really quick manner so like
just um
like
one tenth of a second or something
something uh something like that so
let's say if we can enumerate all the
actions that are supported by by the
environment then uh the question now
becomes how do we translate the
this really sensible action plans
generated by language models but but not
really executable plans
how can we translate that into
those actions supported by environment
or
if you want to deploy some deploy
something in the in the real world let's
say your robot of course 10 actions um
how do you uh map those texts into the
10 actions that the the robot supports
so what we found is that you first need
to enumerate all the actions and then we
found that you can again leverage the um
the world knowledge in this language
models by using another
language model namely here we use
roberta which is a language model really
similar to uh to bert and it's a
different language model because it
essentially um it's a mass language
model so it's really good at outputting
a useful embedding um
like in terms of about the semantic
meaning for for that sentence so what we
do is that we take the sentence
outputted by gpt3 or codex and then uh
we just compare that against all the
possible um admissible actions allowed
actions by the environment and then we
found the most similar one in terms of
like um this distance in the embedding
space um yeah we actually used just
cosine distance and found that to work
decently well
yes so
yeah i have like
there's like an entire space somewhere
and you just place all the actions i
guess you can even pre-compute those
right you can pre-compute the embedding
of all possible actions there and once
my language model outputs anything at
all all i need to do is ship it through
the roberta model get its embedding put
it somewhere get the nearest neighbor
and that's my kind of translated action
so here you have an example that would
that would translate like squeeze out a
glob of lotion into
poor lotion into right hand so this it
would map
yeah action into
and poor
poor it would be the verb lotion kind of
the object and right hand also one of
the objects so maybe like there's two
arguments to pour
um
yeah i mean this makes it is it seems
very simple but i i i was at a talk by
the people who made the first version of
the you know in gmail you you have these
always like three options to respond to
like the quick quick options to respond
right yeah and and
i think the first i'm not sure how it is
done now but the first version of this
we were like wow this is you know you
know cool it actually takes you know it
takes into account the the email message
that was there we always thought it was
kind of like
a language model generative model
somewhere so i went to a talk and they
were just like no we just have a big
list of responses we just classify right
we just take your message right and we
just put it through a model and then we
just classify into this big big bucket
of possible answers so i mean this is
even though it is it is simple it's it's
it's it's very powerful um powerful
method and that being said you don't
even train this you take an
off-the-shelf embedding model and you
compute nearest neighbors and it does
turn out quite well you you do however
you talk about this in the paper there
is a bunch of problems and one of the
problems i see is whenever a step
contains like multiple steps right is
that
like is that a big have you found this
to be a big problem because this just
maps one action to one other action but
if it's like you know
open the fridge and take a glass of milk
then i have essentially no way of
translating that into an admissible
sequence
yeah that's a that's a good question and
i think that's uh one of the sort of
main errors that like this uh this
roberta model that we use it's actually
a sentence alberta model because uh it's
trained with a different objective such
that it can really uh you can actually
calculate cosine uh distance um between
the embeddings they generate so it's a
uh like we found like it's pretty
difficult to map a compounded action
like you said like
um like two actions in one sentence into
one unmutable action but this is um
partly mitigated by
how you tune the temperatures the
sampling parameter uh just the
temperature for the gt3 or codex models
because we found that if you
do increase temperature um then it tends
to output something more um verbally
expressive answers um for each step so
that means it's harder to translate and
we
if you um
if you try like all this like different
settings we
in the end we found like usually you
want to use like a lower temperature
than than what people mostly use for
language generation for example yeah so
so that like each action uh is uh like
small enough and succinct enough and
then and then after we translate this
action uh so it's so that it's easier
for this bird mobile uh roberta model to
translate
and uh yeah something i forgot to
mention like uh after we got this
translated action uh we found that it's
still useful to
put that back to the original prompt put
the translated action back instead of
like the original action so that you can
write the gpt3 and codex model to um to
reason
um like
how am i going to do based on this like
action already performed um so yeah like
you said like you pointed this is the
third uh subfigure here um
so we would take instead of instead of
generating the entire plan at once we
just generate one action then we
translate it and then we substitute
essentially whatever gpt3 output with
whatever the translated thing is and
then based on that create the next
action it makes sense because you it's
it's like almost like a guiding like a
bit of a guard rail uh for
for the language model instead
if you were to let it generate all at
once and then you translate each action
individually they almost like lose
connection to each other right
yeah this here might mitigate some of
this this stuff right if i have a
compound action like go to the fridge
and grab a glass and the closest i hope
that the closest sentence is the go-to
fringe right
um the the language model might still
recover and recognize aha i haven't you
know grabbed i haven't grabbed the glass
yet so that is so these are improvements
one and two and then the third the third
thing you found that really helps is the
prompt up here so the priming which i
think in gpt3 it's very common to have
these priming prompts to tell the model
what
kind of stuff you
you expect as an output i was surprised
to see that you only have one priming
prompt
whereas in general people put more than
one usually people put like three or
something like this is there a
particular reason why you used just one
there is actually now that particular
reason i uh we actually found like uh i
mean uh so in the beginning we we were
we we know that we have this data set
right and then we uh we found
originally we actually tried to train
something to to achieve this but in the
end we found out like we don't even need
to train something and yeah
like
now the question becomes like how like
can you even leverage this data set to
some extent to make it useful um of
course uh this is something like
additional i mean
uh it would definitely be better without
any any of this but if you have this
data set you can
actually found like um this most similar
example uh uh to the query task here uh
for example like this is apply lotion so
um like shave task shape is determined
to be more similar uh yeah again judged
by this roberta model using the same
technique yeah so um
uh i think that that's the that's the
main motivation for using this but we
didn't thoroughly investigate it like
how you structure the prompt whether you
you add like multiple things there and
then um or you change the template here
because i just defined this template
from day one like task something step
one something do something maybe there
is a better template maybe you want to
add some instructions there to make it
better and um so i like i mean this is
definitely possible and we don't
investigate them here because we just
don't just want to get the best
performance out of this we want to show
people like this is something possible
and uh it's really interesting to us so
that's why um
we ended up like um like
just using the the most simple technique
here
yeah and to answer your question why we
don't put multiple uh things here i
think one important reason is like uh
because this example plans that we put
in front are produced by humans and um
this is because to do the space
constraint i'm using a
like oversimplified version uh in this
figure specifically but in uh in fact in
practice these plans are
actually pretty long so um and
they actually already take up a lot of
space uh in the prompt so if you to put
more than one uh sometimes it gets too
long and um i mean it's maybe something
handleable by by larger models but we
just out for the most similar uh most
simple case and i actually read this
like there's a recent paper
investigating why
uh in context learning works they frame
this as a implicit bayesian inference
problem and they did come to a
conclusion that the longer the prompt if
i remember correctly um
like
it helps the model so so in this way you
kind of like trade off the number of
examples you put and the the length of
the of each example so in those cases i
think you mentioned um many people put
many examples um before the query uh
those are usually the
the cases where uh the the tasks they
care about are
um like smaller so for example like you
want to ask
einstein was born somewhere
then like this is a just a sentence
so you probably want to put like more
than one sentence there but this this
case our case is like it's an extensive
action plan so it's already pretty
lengthy and we don't want to go um too
too crazy over here
i mean it's yeah so sorry that their
their recording has stopped on the
screen side but
we can still see it
um
yeah so yeah i was i was i was quite
interested in in that
in the sense of of the prompt
structuring because i know that can also
uh make a big difference but i also like
the sort of approach of not having too
many moving parts you know in
uh in one single in one single thing
because it makes things complicated and
for many papers it
uh it makes you wonder like what was
exactly the thing that gave
uh the the improvement here now you you
do uh very good ablations of all of
these different improvements which i uh
really liked and you showed that kind of
the translation is the the main part
right here although the other things uh
certainly also help have you ever as a
it reminds me a bit of this you know
this retro model uh these language
models that retrieve from the internet
as they produce text it reminds a little
bit of this right in that um you
you
you produce
you go and retrieve the closest samples
in the data set as you produce the text
um it yeah i think the
this combination of retrieval and
generation is picking up steam
uh yeah and and it looks pretty
interesting
my question is a little bit have you
tried also
because essentially you now rely on this
translation procedure to to produce the
correct actions
have you tried any way to like let the
model know what the possible actions are
like something like you know i can
imagine maybe i i you know i ask the
model first and then i get
maybe the five closest actions or the
ten closest actions in embedding space
and then i somehow put these in the
prompt here like you know in between you
know what am i going to do next um is it
this or this or this or this right and
then the model could maybe i could prime
the model to output one of them and
you know
is is there did you try any any way of
telling the model more what's even
possible in the environment because
right now you're essentially relying on
on just the language model itself yeah
that's a really good question too so
like uh we actually didn't try the
specific thing that you talk about like
generate a bunch of
possible actions and then ask the model
again uh which of this are are the best
uh but we did try something similar
which is uh
like bim search so essentially in beam
search you look ahead uh to see like
what guns are um are like having
in the end get the the highest uh
likelihood so um we did try to constrain
the vocabulary um that can be
uh used in in the beam search but this
is only conducted on smaller models
because uh
obviously the gbt3 and codex models are
now open to um fully open to public so
we can we we don't really have full
access to yeah like different features
like um
we can't restrict the vocabulary
dynamically yes so uh i've only done
this on smaller mode uh relatively
smaller models like the gbt neo
and then i think i might have tried on
gpt j as well which is a six billion
parameter model and uh it actually turns
out that they don't do really well with
uh if you really just constrain the
vocabulary that way uh yeah specifically
just that just the beam search
constraining the uh vocabulary we can
generate but uh so my hypo so this is
now thoroughly tested because it's now
investing on larger models as well
but my
intuition why it doesn't work so well is
that this
language models are really trained on
human text so it really
it's you they're really used to how
humans um speak a certain language in
this english so like people don't speak
things in this way step one something
yeah two something step three is
something so that's why if you really
constrain the models this way
a lot of the uh
the the world knowledge encoded in these
models are uh lost so basically um and
personally just a personal opinion i
don't think these models are doing
um like super
intelligent reasoning here it's
basically just doing uh kind of
retrieving what's uh
what it's trained on so uh achieving
this like large scale um text so if you
want to retrieve better you better
adopt the same way that humans speak
a language so uh like if you don't
constrain the vocabulary you can get the
most out of a language model and you can
really tell if you adjust the
temperature um like if you
go different temperature they can tell
you like different um levels of things
and they can be really realistic but if
you really constrain it a lot of this
knowledge is lost and yeah it's it can't
really do too much like common sense
reasoning here
i was you you mentioned this a bunch of
times i was surprised to find
codex as a model and so you you have you
have uh these these are sort of vanilla
models uh and and then you have the
translated ones where all your all your
uh improvements are in there so there is
the the action translation um there is
the sampling even according according to
the probability and executability there
i there is the retrieval of the closest
prompt and so on and these translated
models they perform really well what i
was surprised by and also by the results
is that codex i mean that it's even in
here it's like a code model but also
that comparably it holds up right it's
it's not as good as the gpt3 model but
it's also very very much smaller so you
know parameter by parameter codex is
outshining uh gpt on this task very well
how did you how did you even consider
using codecs and and how can you explain
that this model is is doing so well yeah
so why intuition why uh we actually this
actually came out to be pretty
surprising to us as well so uh we we did
find like this codex models are
really good at generating these plans
and uh actually from my own experience
playing with this models i i did find
like um kodak thinks that this is part
of some dog stream
so yeah it's uh it's actually imagining
like people just like asking the dog
string here but instead of letting keep
generating the code uh we kind of just
stop here so okay yeah let me show the
dog stream for us that's enough so um so
yeah so it's actually doing some this
kind of dog string uh it generates this
doctrine thing and i the reason i think
the smaller codex model are actually
better than the same size uh gbt3 model
is that uh
because it's trained on a more
structured data so like code and
specifically many of this um like this
code examples uh in the data set in the
training data set
consists of docstring and and and and
the code so it not only not only can
handle code really well you can also
generate really realistic documents so
and in people in dog stream they don't
write in um like
they don't write a novel yeah you write
something really
step-by-step and have more structure in
it so that's my intuition why uh
actually does really well with this test
so you can really process this
sequential um
like
logical reasoning better than yeah in
the same uh size gbt3 model but of
course if you use a larger model that
potentially be
more helpful yeah
or i mean there is as you said there is
still a lot of open like questions about
how exactly you structure the prompts
like maybe this step one step two step
three isn't ideal for these language
models maybe you need to more let them
write like a like a reddit post or
something about you know how they how
they went and got a glass of milk
yesterday and then translate that
somehow uh but yeah it's it's pretty
cool so one thing that that just
came to my
attention right here is this top row
right here which i found hilarious so
this is the task is
complete amazon turk surveys so the the
four steps apparently that you need to
do is
walk to home office
sit on chair
switch on computer
look at computer like that's is this the
is this the is this the this is the
description of complete amazon turk it's
a pretty accurate description maybe of
what amazon jerk workers do so like i
said this tests are generated by um
by crowdsource um from the elements and
this uh the humans here happen to be
amazon turkeys so what of them decided
that okay if you want me to
like generate some tasks i would say
like just complete service on amazon
yeah so they decided to put one of this
here and we found this hilarious too so
um
yeah
like like i said so so this language
model so they can't really handle um
anything that you wanted to um yeah so
because we
did put the uh example uh in the front
so
uh i think in this case the example hemp
happens to be something related to
computer and um the the models actually
happen to reason
or potentially you could just repeat the
example but depending on other tasks uh
it doesn't seem like that's the case but
it does come to the reasoning that like
um this might be something related to
computer too and i'm gonna put like this
steps here
yeah yeah i mean this is i mean it has
something like melancholic and it also
has something a bit as you said
rebellious of like you know i'm here
doing my my amazon turk work i'm gonna
you know i'm just gonna put my easter
egg in there in this in this data set or
or like
um show you but it also shows something
i think about the interaction with this
environment because you know if you ask
me you know what did you do today i
could tell you uh you know i programmed
this i viewed a pull request i sent some
email and so on but in the action space
of this environment this would all just
be characterized as go to desk sit on
chair twitch on computer look at
computer and
yeah so so it is really
maybe also a constraint of the
environment um itself and and and it
as i said i think the challenge is going
to be
there's so much knowledge in these
language models and we somehow need to
get it out into the domain that we care
about
and yeah i guess i guess many
opportunities are still there and
in this particular environment
is it so the way i see it we have this
environment it's a 3d environment but
you never actually for your studies you
never actually had to actually execute
anything in the environment is that
correct or do i see something wrong here
uh i think those uh
when you say ask you do you mean like um
like run in the environment
yeah like run the the 3d environment
like actually
give it to the environment because you
evaluate executability you can do with a
parser right uh to see whether it
matches the actions and constraints and
the the correctness you evaluate with
the humans uh because my question was
also a little bit like why can't i just
run it and see if you know at the end
there's breakfast but you already you
already said that the tasks are so
so open like how would you how would you
detect there's breakfast right um
so
so uh in terms of uh so a bit background
here for for the virtual environment so
it comes in two versions one is the i
think they call the evolving graph
version which is a pure like you said a
state machine a a python
like written in python so it just goes
in and then checks which uh
whether the actions can be parsed and
then yeah we satisfy the the common
sense constraint and the other version
they implement uh is this um is this
visual visualized version where they uh
actually only implement a subset of uh
the act the total action supported um
development so i think they uh so in the
evolving graph version the python
version there are 42 actions and in the
visualized version there are only 10
actions so it's limited
uh
like the plans we can generate we can
really visualize are limited so that's
also part of the reason we don't show
the visualized version to humans uh
like can you tell us whether this is
successful or not so um yeah that's
that's a um that's indeed something we
can't do right now
and i think that's like as a community
um as we go go on like
to this next step with more complex
tasks that humans do every day instead
of just like a lower level task
as a community i think more efforts can
be can be put here and um to develop
better uh simulator and also maybe
beyond even household environment so yes
just as a
as a story here i i did play around with
the codex and then gpt3 models to have
it generate something out of the
household domain and seems like they do
have some a lot of knowledge for those
as well so if you can ask how do how do
i pay bills at a restaurant and how do i
work out at the gym and i think um in on
twitter there's also someone who tries
to
after the posting of this paper they
they try to ask the
gp3 model how do i start a company
so yeah they do have a lot of knowledge
for this and as long as you can provide
a set of actions that are um necessary
to complete these tasks uh i think uh no
matter what the granularity is
ideally it should be at the same
granularity as
of of humans so ideally it should be uh
this model should be able to generate
something something sensible and
reasonable but yeah definitely right now
it's something that you definitely can't
trust to put on a robot of course yeah
yeah yeah i mean it's i've always i've
always seen people um
thinking when they think gpt3 or so they
they and they think for example of video
games they always imagine you know we we
can have our npc our characters
that the dialogue be generated by gpt3
so it the dialogue is more realistic but
i think this shows that it can go
further if we are able to map sort of
gpt three's knowledge into
a sort of structured domain that we
choose we could potentially also let
these models generate the action
sequences of like of of characters for
example let's say in video games because
that's like common complaint that you
know the the guards they always walk up
and then down and then left and then
right and then up and then down and
right they have this even if the
dialogue gets really good it their their
behavior is still kind of
lame either that or they they cheat they
know where you are at all times um but
with i feel with models like this we can
almost like take this common sense
knowledge and maybe have the hopes of
transferring that to to various domains
and
infuse a lot of areas with common sense
and that i find that to be i found that
that to be pretty cool yeah in itself it
will be really exciting and interesting
application yeah
yeah so i i mean
there's a lot of a lot of things to be
gay so i what i did i i was specifically
intrigued about clip i don't know if you
are thinking about this or not um but
what i what i try to do is i try to take
like a frame of pacman like and and you
know there's like walls here and here
and uh and and here and i had pac-man be
like you know here facing a wall and
then there's like a ghost behind pac-man
right and and then there's like these
little dots over here to to eat and so
it was like super clear what you have to
do so i try to feed that to clip and you
know you can make a clip classify things
by just evaluating a bunch of different
strings with it so i like try to i try
to evaluate the strings go left go up go
right go down or like pac-man should go
left pac-man should go up but it never
worked out um so if you can if you could
get something like this running this
would be amazing
maybe with your knowledge maybe pac-man
isn't the right environment because clip
was trained on whatever picture scraped
from instagram um but i think just this
this type of
you know thinking beyond just the
strings in terms of language but
thinking in terms of i have some
structured environment and i want to
leverage this this knowledge of these uh
models is is super cool yeah that would
be a super interesting application i
think uh using clip here uh like
because if using another modality which
is image could be really interesting and
so i think it kind of solves uh one of
the major limitations of this paper uh
namely just the um because currently we
generate plants regardless of the
environment state so it doesn't
condition on environment state and
potentially using clip you can encode
something there because you can also
take image as input to um
to an image conserves can serve as
states uh for for
for the environment i think that would
be really cool and um
yeah so um
yeah
so just um to be to be clear to the
listeners that the basic idea for this i
have from from
a phd student that was partially in our
lab called john batista for scandal so
uh the the credit fully goes to him of
of this whole idea i don't wanna but i
just it got me thinking so much about
you know we can extract this knowledge
into into other modalities and that's
that's pretty cool is there anything you
want to maybe
uh say about the
experiments is there anything that was
very surprising to you or you know
something you didn't expect or something
you particularly want to highlight
um
actually i think we cover most things uh
but i think i might say something about
the
the the baseline here i as you can
probably see except for the human
references we also uh got to find some a
g3 version and we did find that fine
tuning can can be a really strong
baseline here because as you can
probably tell the uh one of the measures
here lcs uh which is the longest common
subsequence uh yeah this this measure
here is much higher than the others uh
so this measure basically uh calculates
how much overlapping there is
uh in your generated plants against
those plants written by humans so it's
kind of calculating this um
iou score um so um we we did find that
fund is to be a strong baseline and i
think it it still actually makes sense
to to be a strong baseline because this
is trained on on such data and uh so
this is kind of to illustrate that like
um if you do have domain data it's still
really helpful to to train your models
uh fine-tune your models this way um but
if you don't have something like this uh
you can potentially just leverage the
knowledge already in this language
models
cool um yeah so where
where does your future lie what are you
i i
are you going to are you going more into
this direction or was this sort of like
a one-off thing or do you have
i mean
uh what what are the interesting
questions that that you are asking now
maybe as a follow-up to this yeah so uh
i personally i haven't decided because i
am in the stage where um like uh i'm
applying to phd programs and and and
also uh other positions uh so um
like but but as a follow-up i think it
would be really interesting uh as i
mentioned one limitation major
limitation of of this work is that
we haven't found a clear way to
condition on the environment state so
that like if you really place an agent
in in the household for example there is
no
uh if you want to make coffee but there
is no coffee uh but there is no way
there isn't a automatic coffee machine
how would you make a coffee with some
maybe simpler devices um so
the agent can't really reason uh if you
just put it this way because it doesn't
condition on the environment state so i
think it would be really interesting to
um
like
investigate how you can
also condition on the current
environment and then and then reason
from there um but this might require
some training data and uh i think that's
part of the reason why we don't
like go full length here to investigate
this uh because this is something um
just for us to
uh tell people like this is an
interesting finding and uh we we may be
able to leverage something here um
but i think this will be really exciting
and and like interesting future work
cool excellent uh one long thank you
very much for being here this was
awesome uh so great to hear from you
know from always from the people who
made the stuff so yeah thanks a lot yeah
thank you so much yeah and in the end i
think i also want to like point that
like this is a group effort and really
a lot of thanks goes to uh three of my
advisors
peter bill deepak
and igor mordach
excellent all right thank you and thank
you i hope to see you again
yeah i'm like i it would be a honor to
always to be here yeah
excellent all right all right bye-bye
yeah
[Music]
you